Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Not so long ago, we talked about a neural
image generator that was able to dream up
beautiful natural scenes.
It had a killer feature where it would take
as an input, not only the image itself, but
the labeled layout of this image as well.
That is a gold mine of information, and including
this indeed opens up a killer application.
Look!
We can even change the scene around by modifying
the labels on this layout, for instance, by
adding some mountains, make a grassy field,
and add a lake.
Making a scene from scratch from a simple
starting point was also possible with this
technique.
This is already a powerful, learning-based
tool for artists to use as-is, but can we
go further?
For instance, would it be possible to choose
exactly what to fill these regions with?
And this, is what today’s paper excels at,
and it turns out, it can do, much, much more.
Let’s dive in.
One, we can provide it this layout, which
they refer to as a semantic mask, and it can
synthesize clothes, pants, and hair in many,
many different ways.
Heavenly.
If you have a closer look, you see that fortunately,
it doesn’t seem to change any other part
of the image.
Nothing too crazy here, but please remember
this, and now would be a good time to hold
on to your papers, because two, it can change
the sky or the material properties of the
floor.
And…wait!
Are you seeing what I am seeing?
We cannot just change the sky because we have
a lake there, reflecting it, therefore, the
lake has to change too.
Does it?
Yes, it does!
It indeed changes other parts of the image
when it is necessary, which is the hallmark
of a learning algorithm that truly understands
what it is synthesizing.
You can see this effect especially clearly
at the end of the looped footage when the
sky is the brightest.
Loving it.
So what about the floor?
This is one of my favorites!
It doesn’t just change the color of the
floor itself, but it performs proper material
modeling.
Look, the reflections also became glossier
over time.
A proper light transport simulation for this
scenario would take a very, very long time,
we are likely talking from minutes to hours.
And this thing has never been taught about
light transport and learned about these materials
by itself!
Make no mistake, these may be low-resolution,
pixelated images, but this still feels like
science fiction.
Two more papers down the line, and we will
see HD videos of this I am sure.
The third application is something that the
authors refer to as appearance mixture, where
we can essentially select parts of the image
to our liking and fuse these aspects together
into a new image.
This could, more or less be done with traditional,
handcrafted methods too, but four, it can
also do style morphing, where we start from
image A, change it until it looks like image
B, and back.
Now, normally, this can be done very easily
with a handcrafted method called image interpolation,
however, to make this morphing really work,
the tricky part is that all of the intermediate
images have to be meaningful.
And as you can see, this learning method does
a fine job at that.
Any of these intermediate images can stand
on their own.
I’ll try to stop the morphing process at
different points so you can have a look and
decide for yourself.
Let me know in the comments if you agree.
I am delighted to see that these image synthesis
algorithms are improving at a stunning pace,
and I think these tools will rapidly become
viable to aid the work of artists
in the industry.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!